saludan y grito américa france24 y ya
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros a
la mar bienvenida buena mañana de
miércoles ya estamos a mitad de semana
para hablar de la lucha contra una de
las grandes enfermedades de nuestra
humanidad tenemos nuevos datos sobre la
tuberculosis en todo el mundo mar buenos
días rabo las tías son datos de global
font que es un fondo público-privado que
se dedica a luchar contra la malaria el
vih y también la tuberculosis y queremos
hablar precisamente de estas porque es
una de las que más duramente a curso las
interrupciones de las campañas de
prevención de la pandemia y que poco a
poco se va recuperando pero no lo
suficiente consiguió a global font
tratar 53 millones de personas contra la
tuberculosis pero eso no es suficiente
porque pues porque cada año unas 10
millones se calcula que se contagian un
poquito más de la mitad ha recibido
tratamiento de las que se han contagiado
sigue siendo una cifra después de
cobertura relativamente baja si miramos
en cambio la perspectiva al menos de las
últimas 20 décadas vemos que en el caso
de los nuevos casos de contagio se ha
disminuido un 5% los nuevos contagios de
tuberculosis en los 20 años es una cifra
que es bien distinta de casillas como
por ejemplo el vih que los nuevos casos
se han reducido a la mitad en los
últimos 20 años por lo tanto también
vemos como hace falta este esfuerzo en
cambio en los casos de muertes de
tuberculosis y miramos otro gráfico que
también habla de esto estamos viendo que
la reducción ha sido más significativa
al menos un
21% de disminución de muertes en los
últimos 20 años sigue siendo una buena
noticia aunque no sea suficiente pero
también nos muestra no la realidad de
qué pasaría si no hubiera habido estos
esfuerzos de control en la línea de
arriba
las muertes hubieran superado los 3
millones anuales entonces pues bueno
claramente a pesar de que son cifras
mejor es mejor que nada no necesitamos
más esfuerzos claro más y digamos que
falta entonces para poder combatir
efectivamente la tuberculosis pues para
esto primero es importante recordar que
esta enfermedad le provoca una bacteria
y que afecta sobre todo los pulmones
pero puede afectar también otras partes
de del cuerpo y del sistema uno de los
grandes retos que tiene la lucha de la
tuberculosis por delante es precisamente
la resistencia a los tratamientos y a
los antibióticos sabemos que el uso
desproporcionado el mal uso también es
masivo de este tipo de antibióticos hace
que las bacterias hayan podido
evolucionar para resistirse a estos
tratamientos y hoy en día al menos medio
millón de personas cada año se contagian
de un tipo de bacteria de la
tuberculosis que es resistente a los
tratamientos que se conocen contra esta
enfermedad que pasa además que es un pez
que se muerde la cola no como a medida
que cuanto más tardemos en combatir la
tuberculosis en eliminarla o al menos en
reducirlos su carga sobre pues sobre el
mundo actualmente más tiempo tienen
también más antibióticos se usan para
que se siga desarrollando esta
resistencia a los tratamientos también
que se necesita pues más dinero no
actualmente global fun proporciona más
del 70 por ciento de los fondos
internacionales de la lucha contra la
tuberculosis eso ha sido 8 mil 900
millones de dólares en los últimos 20
años precisamente se está organizando en
las próximas semanas un acto de
recolección para conseguir más dinero
para luchar contra la tuberculosis y
contra estas otras enfermedades que
mencionábamos al principio y ojalá
puedan conseguir el dinero necesario mar
para acabarla lo más rápido posible pero
vamos a pasar a otra tema más porque hay
un efecto de la infección de la
infección por vih de la que no se habla
tanto de qué vamos a hablar si estamos
diciendo el virus de la
inmunodeficiencia humana no que sabemos
que crea el sida si no se trata y una de
las cosas lo que más se conoce es que
altera el sistema inmune ataca el
sistema inmune de las personas para que
no se puedan proteger contra otras
enfermedades pero es que tiene otras
consecuencias de las que no hablamos
tanto veamos un listado de unas de las
efectos cognitivos que tiene el vih
confusión y olvidos dificultad para
concentrarse cambios de comportamiento
incluso trastornos de ansiedad o
depresión no sé si esto te suena a
algunas de las consecuencias que hemos
dado de un virus que últimamente se está
llevando todo el protagonismo el kobe 19
por supuesto es efectivamente no hemos
hablado mucho de la niebla mental
alrededor del cúbito 19 pero es que la
verdad no es lo único pues el único
carlos que provoca eso en total este
tipo de
de disfunciones se llama disfunción
cognitiva puede ser severa o leve y en
el peor de los casos personas en las que
el sida se desarrolle mucho puede llegar
a provocar demencia claro es bastante
complicado no todos estos trastornos que
produce pero pero porque afecta el vih
él está a nuestro cerebro si no es que
el virus afecta a las neuronas
directamente lo que pasa es que afecta
una vez tejido que recubre las neuronas
que ayudan a que funcionen que las
protegen y desencadena también inflama
inflamación en el cerebro y en la médula
espinal lo mismo que veíamos de hecho en
el commit 19 todo esto es lo que puede
provocar estas disfunciones cognitivas
pero es que además es interesante porque
no es el único virus o la única
infección que puede provocar eso no
estamos descubriendo todos esta niebla
mental a raíz del cobit 19 pero esto
lleva afectando desde hace mucho tiempo
muchas personas en una de esas pues
disfunciones cognitivas en este caso de
las que menos se hablan y que más pueden
afectar por ejemplo a las personas pues
en su trabajo en su día a día y que es
muy incomprendido muchas veces no pero
eso sabemos el vih afecta al sistema
neuronal también pueden provocarlo por
ejemplo infecciones de la varicela se
está estudiando todavía si algunas
infecciones o virus de la gripe también
pueden provocar este tipo de
disfunciones cognitivas y aparte de
infecciones por virus también se sabe
qué enfermedades de l'or crónico pueden
llegar a provocar esta niebla mental es
un problema como decíamos relativamente
poco conocido que ojalá a partir de
ahora y del comité de nave reciba
también más atención es que si es
bastante raro confuso no sé si usted se
acuerda o le dio cuando le dio coba 19
pues esta confusión está uno se siente
raro mentalmente totalmente y sigue hay
muchas personas más que le siguen al
cabo de los meses de los años muchísimas
gracias mar por toda la información de
salud mañana por supuesto con más
pasamos a saludar a nuestro segundo
invitado